Once upon a time,
an American moved to London.
And he brought with him
his pet tiger and a toothbrush.
“Well, you've done it again,
haven’t y... [laughs]
...haven't you?”
“Bringing a tiger on a plane?
“What do you want to do with that?
Did you pay for a ticket?”
said the air hostess.
“Yes, I did.
“The tiger is very well traveled,
as a matter of fact.
“And the longer we have this
conversation,
the longer it's more likely
he'll do a s*** on the plane.”
How can a tiger speak?
Because he's very well traveled,
he's educated and s***.
Um...
And at customs they’re like,
“This is not something that's
supposed to happen.
You can't bring Americans to London!”
Okay, you can't bring Americans
to London...
So he brings him to a cat cafe.
Because of the tiger?
Yeah.
I should have gone first.
But they don't stay
because they only serve tea.
Okay?
Okay, do something with that.
[Laughs]
He pointed at one of the
kittens and said,
“This is your fault.
“You're a ginger.
“Why...
...are you so orange?”
“Why do they only serve tea?”
cried the American,
causing a bit of a ruckus.
They go to the zoo next because that's
where the tiger wants to go.
They spot a ball, a football.
All the animals playing in the dark.
It's not the soccer he knows.
He wants to go home.
[Laughs]
What were the last two things?
This is all you.
And the American said,
“The big... [chuckles]
“...problem with London is
there are no decent
“omelet chefs,
and nobody’s talking about it.”
[Chuckles]
And then the tiger growled.
And in the growl the
American could decipher,
“Are you a chef?”
The tiger cuts off his leg
and then makes a human omelet
with...
...lots of chorizo,
ham, and...
...spices from India because
the tiger is from India.
Now that we're on the subject
of tigers and kitchens,
incidentally, tigers are very good chefs.
You know, they have good pan control.
Not a lot of people know that.
One sentence?
The human rose up from
the plate and said,
“I will not be eaten by anybody.”
He walked off into the night
and the American said,
“I’m going back home.”
Thank you very much, everybody.
The end!
The end.
The...
...end.
The end.